>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
I'm Daniel Sheehy.
I'm a curator emeritus of
Smithsonian Folkways Recordings.
And I am pleased to be her
with the founding members
of [foreign language] who
are based in New York City.
And just performed a wonderful
concert at the Library
of Congress where
we are right now.
And so just like to welcome.
>> Thank you.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
The founding members.
>> Thank you.
Thank you [foreign language].
>> Daniel Sheehy: We have
Morris Conjate [phonetic].
We have Ronald Pollo.
And we have Johanna Castaneja
[phonetic] right here
with us so.
Maybe we could start a.
[Foreign Language]
[ Laughter ]
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Johanna.
>> [foreign language] Sure.
Of course.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
Yeah, go ahead.
>> Well.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Tell
us about yourself.
Maybe -- can you -- when you
introduce yourself reach deep
inside and kind of
explain who you really are
and what brought you to
this, this group and music.
>> Of course.
Of course.
Well I mean as, as you
mentioned I am Johanna.
I was born in Bogota Columbia.
I have been in the States
for the last 27 years.
And came with my brother here
you know with a dream of,
of continuing what
we were already doing
in Columbia, back in Columbia.
Music. So it's been 27 years
as of you know studying,
going to school, learning a lot
about not only our own Columbian
music but also other music's
that we've done here so far.
So I've been in a lot of bands.
I've been singing, playing
every kinds of and types
of music you know from
Mexican music to Peruvian music
to Salsa, Puerto Rican yeah to
everything and always trying
to maintain my Columbian music.
Also when I arrived to the
States I, I, I, I was a singer
of [foreign language] you
know Africa -- I'm sorry.
Venezuelan and Columbian music.
And that's all I
knew how to sing.
And.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
That's from the planes
that [foreign language].
>> Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Planes
that, that overlaps both the.
>> Yep.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Venezuela.
>> Exactly.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And Columbia
>> It's a region that we share
with Venezuela and the music
that I, I concentrated most
of my life was from the,
from this region you know.
Although I'm from Bogota I learn
how to dance [foreign language]
since I was very young.
And I learned how to play
some [foreign language].
And I learned how to sing
So I did that for, for a
long time until I arrived
to the States and then with such
a diversity of all this cultures
and all this mixture of
everything, I fell in love
with a lot of things but
also wanted to learn more
about my own country
believe it or not.
Is when you depart your
country is when you realize
that you know that maybe you
should have paid more attention
to your own music and styles
and regions and all that.
So that's when I met this guys
maybe another 18 years ago we
met through a band.
And we were doing
some Columbian music
and you know they taught me
this music from the region
that they are because
I'm from, from Bogota.
They're from the
Caribbean the north coast.
So I've learned with this
guys all this music and I fell
in love and I loved
it as you know.
And since then we've
been you know part --
basically they've already had
that idea of revolu [phonetic].
And they show me really what to
do and, and I've been with them
for the last 10 years now.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And
Ronald Cenetes [phonetic]
who are you Ronald?
>> Okay.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Columbia.
>> Daniel Sheehy: if I
remember correctly that festival
in [foreign language] declared
it to be a treasure of.
>> Uh-huh.
>> A treasure.
>> Daniel Sheehy: A
cultural treasure of.
>> Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Humanities.
>> They did.
>> Yes they did.
>> A few years back yeah.
>> That was like a [inaudible].
>> Restinle [phonetic].
A few years back.
>> That was a few
years ago, yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: It's
a beautiful thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
Congratulations.
>> Thank you.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And
you're part of that.
>> Of course, yeah.
Remember that.
Remember from the.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Uh-huh.
Yes.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Great
to have you here with us.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Columbia.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Recognize the,
the Palence [phonetic] community
as again a treasure of.
>> Yep.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> America.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Right.
Right. The first free
[foreign language] descendant
of community in.
>> Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
All of Americas.
Yeah.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Uh-huh.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
Is that recent?
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Did the
Columbian Culture Administry
have anything to do with that?
[ foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy:
For example or.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Okay.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Uh-huh.
[ foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: So
the truth is we are here
with cultural royalty.
Who've been recognized.
>> Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: At a
world level here in terms
of the traditions
represented right here
on these three chairs.
So, so it's a, it's an
honor to be with you.
>> Thank you.
Oh my God it's an
honor to be here.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So let me ask
you, let's get, get into the --
your music a little bit.
How, how does this background,
how did what you bring to this?
Your family background your
[foreign language] background,
you, your Columbia and, and
eager to learn all kinds
of traditional background.
How does that come out in the
music of [foreign language]?
>> I, I mean from
my part I'm going,
I'm going to say you know it
just really it just really
represents you know our roots.
This music that we do
that definitely represents
a lot of what Columbia is.
I mean if you see [foreign
language] we have different
regions basically within
the same group you know.
Not only that we also do
share this stage with also now
that we're in the States we
share the stage with people
from other countries
too like from Mexico.
We have some people from here
the States play Columbian music.
So it's, it's you know for us
it's a privilege to be able
to have other cultures
involved within our culture.
And that they're willing
to also learn and, and,
and take that step of,
of learning our culture,
our rhythms and play
the music with us.
So you know we express
definitely everything
that we brought from Columbia.
Again I mentioned before
that once you're away
from your country is when
you're really want to learn more
and start doing the research
of everything that Columbia has
to offer because we want to be
the ones taking this message
to the world of saying
this is what we have.
This is the music that we have.
This is our instruments.
This is the Afra-descendants
you know all this regions
that we want to share
with you so.
You know that would
be from my, my side.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So I notice
both times that you said
when you leave your country
you realize how much you didn't
learn that you want to
learn and you go for --
both times you said that
Ronald was nodding his head.
>> Yeah.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
[ Foreign Language ]
>> I remember when the
-- my first time come to,
to United State you know
I see so many culture
so many culture together
like Puerto Rican, Cuban.
You know every, every other
culture Mexicans and everything.
But I don't see anything
like Columbia.
Like I say this is a I
can say this group is
like Columbian traditional
music.
I don't see that.
So that was more my
I say I'm effort.
>> Effort.
>> Effort to, to say like.
>> We need to do.
>> I got to, I got
to do the band.
I got to make a band that
has Columbian flavor there.
>> That represents.
>> Represent.
>> Yeah, Columbia.
>> Columbia.
And, and that and, and
because I know the regions.
I know how every did
for long time ago.
We play you know all
the time in Columbia.
I said is it the time?
Is it the time to
make new music?
Is it time to make [foreign
language] for, for Columbia
for [inaudible] and bring
to here to, to United States
and play with other
people to no Columbia.
>> Not only Columbia.
>> Columbia.
Play with everybody.
So that, that's my
[inaudible] more my --
how do you say [inaudible]?
My -- me.
>> Inspiration.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Right away as soon as you go
through Columbia you're
going to smell that.
The flowers.
And you're going to say wow.
It's true.
It's so different.
>> You're going to say
why didn't I smell that?
>> Yeah. You know why don't,
why don't pay attention
to it before?
So I.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> We try to teach everybody
about Columbian music
and show you know the
tradition the and everything.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> One day we're going to
do a Wayawa [phonetic] tree.
>> Tree.
>> Here.
[ Laughter ]
[ foreign Language ]
>> Welcome to.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Columbia.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
Like scrambled eggs.
[ Laughter ]
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Uh-huh.
>> Sounds good.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah,
that's a good name.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: And it's
close enough to revolution
that you get into
that if you want to.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
[ Foreign Language ]
>> No, they, they say oh why
is that revolu -- revolution.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
>> Why is on revolution.
But you can say revolu.
>> Revolution.
[foreign language] if
you want to call it that.
>> Revolu [phonetic] is more
a lot of stuff together.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
Yeah. So, so, [inaudible]
so, do you borrow
from other [foreign language]
tradition from Columbia
like from the pacific or
from [foreign language] even,
which is?
[ Foreign Language ]
>> We have, we, we, we did
one, one grado [phonetic]
from the pacific called
[foreign language].
>> Daniel Sheehy: Uh-huh.
>> And it's [inaudible] like
really like we will meet
up very good friend in New York
called Diego Ragone [phonetic]
and he teach us to all
those kind of rade --
[foreign language]
and, and other
but for Revolu [phonetic] we
only use [foreign language].
>> That, that's the
only one that we use
from the pacific yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And [foreign
language] it mean from the,
from [foreign language].
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> From the region.
Yeah.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Like states.
>> Yeah.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah, for
that whole pacific thing.
But you all from the north.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> The Caribbean.
>> Daniel Sheehy: The Caribbean
[inaudible] at any rate.
So can you tell us a
little bit -- talking --
let's, let's maybe hone in on
some of the, the details here.
What's that and what's
that and what's that?
Can you talk to us about that?
>> So that one is our
[foreign language] you know.
And it's a I mean that one is
basically it maintains obviously
a rhythm but it's also used
for a lot of improvisation.
It's probably going to be the
loudest one you know it's the
happy drum.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yes.
>> If you translate it you know
[foreign language] is the happy
drum because it's happy
the whole time you know
as it's always improvising.
And then we move to
the [foreign language]
which you some other countries
do share same [foreign language]
you know maybe --
made differently but played
the same way with sticks.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Uh-huh.
>> And this basically.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Sideways like?
>> Yeah, yeah.
Sideways.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Uh-huh.
>> You play sideways.
And it's, it's going to be
basically our base you know.
It's going to do that base
sound you know on the music.
And then usually this is smaller
version of that a very tiny one.
It's called [foreign language]
you know which is usually the,
the three instruments will
create the Afro-Columbian
percussion session.
>> Daniel Sheehy: [foreign
language] means calling.
>> Yeah.
>> Because it's always
calling a beat basically.
So [foreign language] is only
maintaining one beat the whole
time throughout any
rhythms you know.
And then we have the
[foreign language] you know
which this is the
[foreign language]
which is the female right?
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
>> This usually a male version.
Just the difference is that
it would have only two,
two holes to cover.
This one keeps the whole
melody throughout the songs.
The other one will just
hold long notes throughout.
>> The base.
>> The songs and also yeah.
It creates support.
So this [foreign language]
is very interesting
because this body part is
made out of a cactus tree.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Uh-huh.
>> The inside of the cactus.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Right.
Yeah.
>> And then the, the,
the head part is bee wax
with charcoal mixed in and
kind of mold into this head.
And then usually the mouthpiece
is a, a, duck feather so.
>> Daniel Sheehy: I
don't know if this may --
just for me this maybe one
of the most easily identifiable
instruments in the world.
The style of playing
and the sound of.
>> And the sound.
>> Daniel Sheehy: These.
Yeah when you hear that you
don't think Venezuela you don't,
you don't.
>> Right.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
You don't think Peru.
You don't think.
>> Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
Canada you know.
You think Columbia.
>> Columbia yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah that's [inaudible].
>> Daniel Sheehy: Can, can
we just hear a little bit of?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Something's that called
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
[ Music ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Is that
your [foreign language] are?
[ Foreign Language ]
>> That's right.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> It's one of the first songs
I learned on the flute yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: [foreign
language] that was in the,
the Cultural Education
Program, is that what?
>> It, is, is yeah.
Lot of schools have that kind.
This song this one with
song everybody teach.
>> You learn the, the,
the [foreign language]
at the school.
>> I learn with my, my --
I remember my teacher
he teach me a little.
In those days they don't
have any schools like now.
>> Yeah.
>> For now like now.
>> Now is different.
So now they are more
schools and --
but in those days my teacher
only teach me the positions and,
and, and basically say okay
now you need to made some use.
>> Yeah.
>> So I just started you know.
I start learn the songs
of the [foreign language].
I got to, I got to
take this song out.
I got to made it.
You know that's how I, I
learn the [foreign language].
Now I make my own songs
with the [foreign language].
That what I try to.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So
this was the 1990's?
When were you learning?
When was this?
>> That was in 19 7?
>> Daniel Sheehy: 2000?
>> Yeah, no.
1987, 88 something like that.
>> Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: 87 yeah.
So [foreign language].
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> [foreign language] have
been around for a long time.
[ foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
>> My father's time.
>> [inaudible] time yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
Did you -- sorry?
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: What you?
Or what would that be?
I don't know.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> No. No.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
Yeah. Right.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> [inaudible] like a native.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
Yeah. So, so you
took this instrument?
How -- did you --
I meant to ask.
What is the most
famous group that?
Is there a group that
is the role model the --
you mentioned the.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
Yeah.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> They are you know, they
are the I say the first one.
Right?
>> Yeah.
>> Like the most promote
Columbia guida [phonetic] music
around everywhere.
They everywhere.
They also win the
Grammy or something.
>> Daniel Sheehy: As I recall
their Folkways CD that you.
>> Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: [foreign
language] produced won a
Latin Grammy.
>> Ah. Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And they
brought up [foreign language]
from Columbia to open
the Latin Grammy's.
>> Yes I remember.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> I watched that.
>> I remember.
Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
That was really cool.
>> It was.
Amazing. Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So a -- let
-- do [foreign language] here.
What, what -- can you explain
what, what do you put into it
in terms of rhythms or singing?
You, you -- from your point
of view into the music?
Into the music of [foreign
language] of what you have here?
Is it drumming or singing
or whatever it might be?
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: I heard
melodies the center of Columbia
like little turns of melodies
like even the one with.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Just
little turns of melodies
that sound very Columbian to me.
It didn't sound Mexican.
It didn't sound.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: You know
whatever -- sound like.
Of course when you're on stage,
your motions there are a lot
of moves that are, that are
that you could say ah
that's Columbian, right?
Am I right about that?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Of course.
Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
And then of course
the, the instruments,
the rhythms the genres
and all that so, so,
so really your music just
filled with Columbian --
just about everything.
>> Yeah.
>> Sure.
>> Daniel Sheehy: It just comes
out every, every, every turn.
Every.
>> Yeah. No.
For sure it's, it's Columbian.
This is I mean that's, that's
the message we want to.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
>> You know take across
that this is Columbian music
you know.
Although we have other people
that play that are not Columbian
or they're putting
maybe there input.
We want to focus the, the
traditional rhythms and want
to explain what we're
playing and you know.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Uh-huh.
>> So they know we're
playing a [foreign language]
or we're playing a
[foreign language] what this
instrument is.
So yes it's -- that's
what we want.
We want.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And the
creative process who, who --
are you three the leaders?
How does that work?
>> The, the creative I mean
-- it's going to be funny.
And it's going to sound
funny you know how I'm going
to say this because.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Okay.
Good.
>> Ronald and I we're
actually husband and wife
and we share you know
our life together.
So not only the musically
but at home we have two
little girls you know.
We have a whole life together.
So a lot of the creation
it's basically me cooking
in the kitchen and right next
to the kitchen he has his
little studio, home studio.
>> That's the best
spot, the best spot.
>> Where he sits.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> So basically I'm in the stove
you know warming or cooking
and he's playing something.
And he's telling me so
what do you think of this.
And I'm like cooking.
And I might go yeah that's
sounds oh no that one is wrong.
No I don't think you know
we're basically back and forth.
And a lot of the creation
part of the starting of,
of a song a new song,
goes basically like that.
So you know he definitely
the main person
that has the inspiration.
He comes home every
day with new songs.
I have to say if anything
he has five more CD's
that we can record today if we
want to because he has a lot
of inspiration you
know through our live,
through his daily routine,
through, through his family.
>> Through my friends.
My friends.
>> Friends.
I mean he has a lot
of inspiration
and he has a huge talent
and he you know the
thing that God gave him.
And he comes up with
songs all the time so.
>> Daniel Sheehy: When he said
he has a studio right next
to where you're cooking
I know he was a wise man.
[ Laughter ]
>> Daniel Sheehy:
And a smart husband.
>> Right? He did
that for a purpose.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yes.
Do you have other?
>> Smells so good
inspiring like right away.
>> He gets inspired
by the smell.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Do you have
other lives other than music?
>> Yes.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
I mean parents.
>> Yes. Parenting is one.
And I mean music is
a, is a tough business
to survive on you know.
It's -- we.
>> Especially in New York.
>> Especially in a, in
a city like New York
where every day is
more expensive to live.
So you know musician's life
in New York is a tough one.
It's a very tough.
So we have to help ourselves
through other things.
So we do have other jobs.
We, we do have them part time.
We are not 100% because
this is what really we want
to do this 100%.
We want to do it full time.
And so we, we made that
choice that we want
to just work a tiny bit
just to support our family.
And support ourselves in
this big expensive city.
But music is what we want to do.
You know I mean.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
>> every time we
come to a concert,
every time we take a trip
and we go back home is
when we really realize that we
should really be doing music
100% because it's what we
really enjoy and love doing.
So we, we keep working
everyday to get this band
and this music more to other
cities, other countries
and we want to get this music
across and we want to be able
to live 100% from
this from something
that we really, really enjoy.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Is that
the, [foreign language]?
>> Yeah.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Who,
who is your audience?
Who are, who are the
people that, that you?
>> That's very, very interesting
because we had [inaudible].
>> Yeah.
>> Columbia and we got
people from United States.
>> States.
Yeah.
>> People from even from, from
one of the guys from Armenia?
Armenia something like that?
>> We have a lot of followers.
>> That's funny because.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Armenia?
>> Armenia.
>> Armenia and they follow
us everywhere where we go.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Is that right?
>> Yeah.
>> They say we love you guys.
We love you guys.
Do you understand what we
say> no but I don't care.
I love your music.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> I think we had any type
of audience you know this music
we love to interact with people.
And we want to get
everyone dancing.
Everyone singing.
Even if they don't know.
We roughly go quickly
what we're doing
so they know and a you know.
Again our main focus here
is to get across anything.
And it doesn't matter
if you're not Columbian.
We just want to get
the music out.
>> Daniel Sheehy: You know I
this is just my impression.
So.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: That there's
a certain internal piece there
that you have that
allows you to be creative.
And I kept thinking
about values.
I just wonder if do you
ever talk about values
about [foreign language]?
Is there something that you
feel like you share there
at least the three of you?
I know sometimes you have
to call musicians to come in
and they do their
job and all that.
But you know do you have like
a mission in your mind or a set
of values for the
[foreign language]?
>> Oh well.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Uh-huh.
>> Yeah. I think, I think it
definitely the values we express
in, in how we are trying to
stay together as a family,
as friends, as you
know musicians trying
to get this band together.
And it comes from our
backgrounds you know,
our families.
You know our -- that
we definitely,
we're taught what a family is,
what your roots are
who you are you know.
Where you're coming from
and just to get this
and do your best to
get this out there.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Uh-huh.
>> So I think values are
definitely a number one in,
in us.
And you know I think
we have great,
great ones from where we're
coming from great families
that taught us great things.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Uh-huh.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Manhattan .
Or Brooklyn or.
>> Queens.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Queens.
In Queens.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> New Jersey.
>> In New Jersey.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> In Manhattan in
Brooklyn, Bronx.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> In New Jersey.
>> On Facebook.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Facebook.
>> And Twitter and
Instagram and You tube.
And.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Uh-huh.
Your Grammy.
>> Ah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Thank you all
for listening to this interview
with three wonderful
individuals.
I say wonderful because
they're wonderful musicians
and wonderful human beings.
>> Thank you.
>> Thanks.
>> Daniel Sheehy: With
a deep sense of purpose.
I was very, very impressed
it comes off loud and clear.
And, and on behalf
of anyone else
out in our viewing audience,
thank you so much
for what you do.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you guys
for bringing us here.
>> Daniel Sheehy:
Which legacy to,
to be part of not only
this countries culture
but the worlds culture.
>> Yeah. Thank you.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.